taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
roll this right now because this idiot i
told you
welcome to tastebuds welcome he says to
me
okay twinkies right nobody's gonna be
twinkies i say joe do yourself a favor
the only thing that's gonna be twinkie
is a devil dog you say you can't argue
on behalf of devil
no problem there but i can't argue
against the twinkie so we can't have an
episode twinkie versus devildog
so we're saving twinkie for you agree
that there's nothing better than a twin
there's nothing better than this
so you and i are going to face off
against someone else with a twinkie yes
so i said all right let's t what's going
to face off against the devil dog
we named a list of things i said i bet
you have a great shot with a yodel how
about a ring ding right i said that
right there's even those apple cakes
there's
all those those packaged like cakes uh
your hostess drakes by the by the front
he goes i'll take snowballs i said
that is a bold choice it's bold
snowballs
i don't think you stand a chance in hell
a snowball's chance in hell this isn't
what i thought snowballs were
you [ __ ] the tweet is out what do i do
now what are the pigs
what are you gonna say snowball's pink
coconut pink yeah yeah yeah that's a
white one and that's
oh okay no you're almost over the place
i want to let you in should i even
reveal behind the my there we are
there's my snowballs there's my babies
yeah but that was the exact thing you
just saw oh okay
no no no you're back oh yeah yeah you're
back i'm back yeah you're back in the
new york groove
i'm back i've never seen the white ones
i was like what is that man
now listen we're coming in hot
we're coming in real hot get off your
phone wait someone just texted me
kit kats are trending on twitter
i'm not kidding i know shut up no i
don't
i it can't be because of us so
what is that a coincidence it's not
because i mean
40 000 question mark we did have 50 plus
thousand votes on it just now but i
can't imagine it's from us
maybe kit kat picked up the poll and
it's you think so
maybe i don't know but listen here's the
thing
let's not go off the rails with the did
you put the phone down
we have a show to do so what you said to
me moments ago
and and it pulls out he goes well i go
you're really going to take snowball
because
i snowballs i know and i understand that
that's all it
all it takes for us to have a proper
debate we need passion
behind something and that's it it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're not
conceding that
a devil is probably more popular of a
choice than the snow
it is what it is yeah of course
about that but then i pressed you
because i actually i am snowball adverse
i think that the snowball is like it
never came together for me well listen
i've said it to you before and i'll say
it again
you're not smart
this man this man if i could call him
that
he he just moments ago he goes well you
know what i love about the snowball
that graham cracker layer and then me
and pimp looked at each other like i'm
sorry did he
like i thought the bottom part was a
chocolate covered graham cracker
it's not and then we said well there's
no graham cracker in it and you go yes
there is they go
there's no graham cracker and i go i go
well
you know why it could go up against the
devil at least both cream-filled treats
we were trying to figure out what to
name the episode because we can't say
best cake
so he said best sweet treat i'm like
maybe it's the best cream-filled cake
not the episode the pole the pole the
pool yeah so i think it's the best
cream-filled cake he goes
snowballs don't have cream in the middle
because i go what
of course they do that's the main
ingredient in the middle so here's a man
that is about to argue for a treat that
he thinks has graham cracker and no
cream in it no devil dogs had a candy
shell like that i thought
that's a fudge dip devil dog okay i tell
you what i'm not even gonna go
to fudge dip devil dogs all right first
double dog's been off in 91 years
whoa i haven't had that now hold on that
state of 2017
did that last did fudge dip devil dogs
last a test of time
so wait a minute are they in my local
grocery devil dogs were invented
in almost the night in 1890s cakes
that's what they are that's what it is
ah not sweet treats
nobody knew it i mean i wanted to be the
keeper at home i said it's a cake it's a
cream-filled crepe it best i wish and i
wish
if the cake is a if the people at home
could see the deliberation before every
poll goes out
you really think somebody's going to
look at it and be like what the hell is
a sweet treat i'm lost
no nobody didn't no it's just an
indicator of how much
i care i don't care okay this is look at
this we have
we have we have we have a mosaic
listen to me listen to me it's just that
cake uh
listen to me uh you wanted to bring in
little debbie no you want to bring tasty
cakes but it's regional
it's not big enough you can't take on a
goliath like drake's
with a tasty cake you just can't do it
okay fine let's get
let's let's get the first thing out of
the way nothing beats a twinkie that
needs to be
explained nothing beats a twinkie we
need to we we need to do more than just
establish that we need to talk about it
a little bit
nothing beats a twinkie the twinkie is i
don't even know what
i gotta tell you i don't know why
brother i don't know why it's so good
you look at that thing you go it's
golden
yeah it's moist it's spongy
it's it's it's probably smaller and not
as good as when we were younger like all
of them
sal can i tell you something yeah i
never ate them growing up
because oh they were my favorite here's
the thing there was twinkie the kid was
on the packaging yeah
i love the old packaging all this new
packaging by the way all the graphic
design artists they need to calm down
and we need to go we need no we need to
go back to simplicity
put the goddamn kid on the thing and
just make it like i just want it to be
like
good no no no no as a kid i never ate
them why
there was no icing there was no
chocolate but but
i'm i'm gonna yeah we're on the same
page right now no i love
that yeah okay when i finish my thought
please
no you said you know what i love and i
said when i finished my thought okay
anyway
so you when i was a kid i wouldn't go
near him i was like
i don't have time for this there's
cupcakes out there plus i grew up in
your tasty cake oh
you know what you could have done you
know what you could have did the
freaking cupcake that goes like that i
don't want the cupcake that goes like
that i want the snowball can we stay
on big target big contender we're
talking about twinkies right now
yeah i never touched them i didn't care
and then when they announced twinkies
might go out of print remember when that
was happening
yeah and they said they were going to
start they did and somebody saved them
yeah when they announced that i was like
oh [ __ ] man i should go get a twinkie
and that's when i realized at that age
i was well into my 30s well into my this
was like a few years ago and i was like
holy [ __ ] these things are amazing
and that's the thing with the twinkie
everything you said is right it's cream
it's soft it's moist it's golden
but here's the thing if somebody put two
cakes in front of you
and one was like a chocolate on
chocolate and chocolate and
and then they put that twinkie cake next
to it you'd be like the chocolate cake
is the one
if you didn't know that's what i'm
saying if somebody put fillings
on a table and one of them was like the
yellow custard
and then they and then so and or the gel
whatever and then somebody pointed to a
bowl of that twinkie filling you'd be
like that
is gonna taste like crap they inject
that boring nothing cream
into that brown beige
oh it's i would say golden yellow yeah
and it's like and it becomes
magical i don't know what the hell it is
they were like it looks like an
unfinished product that's what i'm
saying it looks like
it looks like somebody hit the conveyor
belt and they just shot off on
on on frosty yeah you know what i mean
and
the thing about it is this the texture
of a twinkie just it's so good it's got
a little give
but then it just bursts with the cream
in the middle and then you know what i
really like i like the underside where
you see the three injection points of
the cream i like the i don't know why
it does something for me i like that
they were like we're gonna try and
really
really um really put the cream out in an
even manner
so we have three entry holes because you
know they could have just plugged the
side of it
and shot cream in longer but it would
have never worked out they could have
done it
but it also speaks they could also
easily fill those holes up somehow with
some kind of magical cake
yeah synthetic around the other thing
but my point is is that that lends to
your
argument of it looks like an unfinished
product they didn't even bother to cover
the holes up
they're just this is what it is it's
like when you go into a great dive bar
and the pipes and the wires are all
exposed
and you know and you're just like i like
this place man it's i know what i'm
getting at
for you anything else i don't think i
think they did away with twinkie is that
recent
because i thought they did away with
twinkie the kid as the mascot
like see that like twinkie people don't
even know
see that that would have been the kid
was only on the
individually wrapped ones he wasn't on i
think the numbered
no that's not true he was on the box
like a son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah
i think the only look at that boy is
that a boy is he a man who is he
what a kid oh he's a kid he's a kid oh
he's a man yeah but it doesn't matter a
30 year old kid walks by me i say call
him a kid because i'm
15 years old it is strange that they
said what do you want to do for the
mascot do you say let's do
a bloodlust outlaw
parody
you know what you're so right because
not the thing about it like
take blood lust out of it the fact that
they're like there's a snack cake that
we're gonna sell by the register
what will best encapsulate how we want
people to feel about this
how about a cowboy yeah yeah that
doesn't make any sense
throw a cowboy hat on the twinkie the
kid mascot logo was created by denny
lesser
a route delivery a root to root route
delivery driver from hostess
in the san fernando valley he designed
the mascot and his wife made the costume
that he used for traveling promotional
campaign so this wasn't even like this
was
so how did how to talk about hostess at
large
take his his thing talk about working
your way up
the ladder dude it's this guy's drive
this guy's
kevin james in it king of queen style
driving the truck
he comes in with the mask all i want to
do
is come right home and give a twinkie to
you yeah i love that show this baby all
my life i will be
coming to you uh can you scroll up a
little right there
twinkie the kid is an anthropomorphous
and anthropomorphized
i always get that word it's tough one
twinkie appearing as a
wrangler he wears boots gloves a
kerchief
with hearts i didn't know that it always
had hearts on i had no idea
and a 10 gallon hat with the words
twinkie the kid on the brim what is his
though what is his
place of what is his purpose look at
that thing though they had toys of it
i would love a twinkie to keep yeah i
know now i want one i see i do
this for the next
do i want one it's a fun tattoo can it
for the i'll get one too we both get it
i'll get it i'll get it too
it won't really go with my like
everything else on my body i'm getting
the frasier logo
i'm getting my whole thing really yeah
i'm getting the frasier logo on my arm
tall
yeah yeah it's my favorite sitcom of all
time my body's uh my tattoos they've
made there's no rhyme or reason anyway
yeah yeah uh wait a second though uh
pimp look up
twinkie the kid toy because this is what
i'll do now for the next
and i guarantee on ebay they're like
four thousand dollars probably
you know oh wow pop pops made it twinkie
the kid
i don't want the pops one i want vintage
wow
how much is this thing see all buying
options
click on did he ever did they ever give
him a voice
no he's still around that's a new toy
did they ever give him a voice like in a
commercial did he ever speak
or like lasso someone he had a thick
bolivian accent
very strange uh alan's
oh my god was the voice of twinkie the
kid pimp can we play tweaking the kids
are you two steps ahead of me he'll
return after these messages i love
saturday morning
oh god wasn't it such a better time
is twinkie the kid ever wonder how they
get that creamy filling into the middle
of a twinkie
you know how we get it we see the holes
you [ __ ]
can you pause please can you pause a
little respect
i mean it's a stupid premise for the
commercial but
i i want to know how they are going to
pitch to us that the cream gets in there
for certain and by the way twinkie the
kid has the voice of a 70 year old man
yeah
i mean it's not he wasn't like hey
that's drinking the cat that's what i'm
saying it's not it's like billy the
billy kid wasn't really a kid oh so
they're not even telling you he's just
an outlaw
he's billy the kid the kid doesn't
indicate age is what you're saying
no they're just they're doing this
parody of billy the kid
yeah yeah billy kid was like 18 17. no
you know i know
i know billy the kid but i never pieced
together that twinkie the kid was
pulling from billy the kid and it's
i mean utterly obvious and until i just
said this yes that's correct
when i said blood lust out well earlier
you howled
yeah because yeah i know you didn't
at that point when i said that you
didn't put together i was talking about
billy the kid well
no yes but no no i mean
his identity as a bloodlust outlaw yeah
i guess you're right i don't know it's
just something i never would love to
crawl inside that brain of yours
i want to know what's going on in there
really i never really i want to know
what is going on like the next thoughts
past it like you know i mean so i never
really was like oh like
this is billy the kid's story and this
is twink you know like i don't know i
thought they were just like
this is a little kid a kid
that's also dressed as a cowboy with a
name
uh that parodies the most famous cowboys
i don't even might have been like a
young 20 year old or
high teens okay but his voice is such
that he has like his throat cancer
where do we are no they did he was he
was this is where the cream comes from
it's a
all right all right where do you think
he's gonna tell us the cream comes we
know where it comes from holes are
exposed
i can't believe the audacity that
there's no no no no no i don't think he
said how it gets oh did he say how it
gets in there
where does it come no how it gets
interesting
because he was screaming over twins
this is twinkie the kid ever wonder how
they get that question
into the middle of a twinkies cake well
these kids have some pretty good ideas
first they put down the creamy feeling
then they baked the cake all around
see they got this big tube full of the
stuff
and it just squished that kid arrested
his wife
what hostess twinkies cakes what's she
saying
there's the old packaging yeah the fresh
snacks
with us back when you got two in a pack
yeah what do you mean
twinkies eventually went solo packs no
because price point on a solo twinkie
that can't be wrong oh twinkies
definitely went solo packs at one wait
did they no i might be individually
wrapped in the
box of 10. look what comes up adorable
twinkie
i'll twink no didn't uh you're right
you're right i'm wrong i'm sorry oh they
do still have
now see sometimes they put them on the
box and sometimes they don't
it's a real bastardization on that box
now though man that's not the twinkie
they're getting too they're getting too
flashy with the graphic
with the with the graphics on on the box
keep it simple
all right so we've established who the
hell is that
some guy okay can i say one other thing
i love about the twinkie
which normally it would be a downside
for another cake you know when you pull
it off the
wax white cardboard a lot of times it
retains that darker golden under layer
you know and when you peel it off it
rips off and really if you want a full
bite you want that on the bottom but
actually i don't mind it you know
because everyone because then we do is
you take your finger right
and then you run it along that wax
cardboard and you just
scrape up that whole bottom cake and
then you pop it in that way
part of eating it i'm not above this
folding that in half with the cake part
out
tooth drag across i've never done this
pulling it in
like cupcake wrapper style oh i've never
done that not against that at all
but then but then really the top and the
bottom of your mouth are really
on the wax cardboard until the cake
shoots out from the middle of it no no
no this is what i'm saying no no not in
the middle
no the middle would be the way cupcake
cupcake wrapper style is a bad analogy
that's how it is with cupcake wrapper
i'm saying you got the cake on this side
you fold it
cake side out oh the whole twinkie
itself you you
know the the cardboard the cardboard
the thing that you were just talking
about yeah i know but
you were the one who did a terrible job
at describing what you meant
pimp am i nuts who am i talking to here
i get it yeah i get that teeth along and
pull the cake off of it i get that i get
that especially if you're out and about
your hands aren't sanitized
i mean i'm just saying it's a little bit
of fun it's a little bit of fun
yeah i i agree with you listen you ever
go in there and try to get the cream out
first
i never did that no they ever like break
in half and then suck no
no i'm assuming there are other ways to
do it no it's that
let me tell you about it sound off in
the comments how do you eat a twinkie
a twinkie i'm telling you something a
twinkie is like a mcdonald's
cheeseburger
you separate those elements and you're
dealing with some tough stuff
here we go you keep that that's what it
goes together dude
you're saying that for the twinkie the
sum of its parts is way greater than
it's individual
yeah if you it would be like if you suck
just the cream out it would i'm sure it
would taste fine but it would be like
just
peeling the cheese off of mcdonald's
quarter pounder you can be like
this just doesn't it's just not right
can you read that
uh uh new jersey didn't take
the kids forced retirement lightly he
rattled off a letter of contention
content i'm so dumb
when they were talking about the mascot
of twinkie the kid this 13 year old
wrote uh wrote to them
he rattled off a letter to the continent
to continental requesting the
kids reinstatement complete with 135
signatures
on a petition promising to boycott the
company's products
as long as our hero is kept away from
the public
the threat worked and when twinkie the
kid made his triumphant return two years
later in 1990
continental baking reached out to the
kid
to let him know his pleas had hit home
wow
there you go i i contend that they
didn't give a flying f about what the
kid did
and when they decided to bring it back
on their own they scoured
their correspondence and said let's spin
this into a nice marketable
thing yeah that's what i think that's i
would agree i would agree the uh
that's why it took him two years to
reinstate it uh
i mean look at that he looks like a he
looks like a hopped up meth addict
terrible twinkie the kid looks like he's
just gonna he he doesn't
he doesn't he just nothing about that
box makes me want to buy the twinkies
that's a gen z twinkie the kid right
yeah it's it's just it just sucks it's
too sterile it's like it doesn't have
any texture to it man
we're really going and then anyway let's
just get twinkies by the way
all right let's say it together nothing
beats a twinkie
all right and on to the battle of the
day joe you've heard of the fork
the fork you've heard of the knife good
knife you've heard of the
spoon i love this book
what if the spoon was magic i thought
the spoon already was
magic yeah okay it's helping me get
cereal into my mouth
that's right but i have a feeling you
have something more to say well you know
our listeners already know where we're
going because magic spoon's been with us
for a while and we're moving boxes we're
moving products here
okay that's why they keep coming back we
love them they love
us and the world spins round and round
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein
which tell me another cereal where
you're getting that kind of protein
you're making gains
while you're eating cereal right only
four net carbs in each serving so that's
keto friendly how about gluten
nope gluten-free how about green sorry
charlie grain free how about soy don't
you dare soy free
a lot of carbs no low carbs what about
gmo everybody wants a gmo no you don't
because it's gmo free it's gmo free and
i gotta tell you i have no idea what gmo
is but it's not in there and i know
that's a good thing and you're not
paying for it
so look here's the greatest part they
got a new flavor i'm very excited about
this
birthday cake flavor i love birthday
cake flavor things
i love birthday funfetti cake is is
terrific oh my god are you nuts
how about how about getting a birthday
how about it's your birthday
and you have birthday cake cereal that
morning why are you waiting for the cake
at night that's right start the day off
right
you start celebrating when you rise and
shine and i'll tell you what they got
magic spooner's birthday cake
uh packs available it's a special five
pack it's limited
it's available for a limited time only i
say this do you go get yourself a five
pack of birthday cake magic
spoon give a box of it away to your
closest friends and family on their
birthday
what a nice present oh that is actually
a good idea yeah you can also build your
own box
make the flavors that you want uh the
pick the flavors you want they got cocoa
they got fruity they got frosted they
got peanuts and if you're in canada
it's available to you too as well right
now so go to magicspoon.com
taste buds to grab the new limited
edition birthday cake or a custom bundle
of your own
choosing today you're going to use promo
code taste buds when you get there
you're going to get five dollars off
your first order that's magicspoon.com
tastebuds
and use the promo code tastebuds to get
five bucks off
this is your way to deliciously
healthy cereal foe
and i just want to piggyback on what you
said you damn straight
you give someone a box of cereal for
their birthday they're gonna be thrilled
you know learning a second language i
gotta tell you uh in high
school war college was not exactly
what i'd call a high point in my
history of academia i still have no idea
how to use vosotros
i was so bad at it i i failed i almost
failed spanish two full years in a row
in high school wow
uh i had a really really tough time
learning
and i am very grateful
that there are companies now like babel
which is the number one selling language
learning app
out there that are giving you basically
an addictively fun and
easy way to learn language for once
whether you're
going to travel abroad or connect in a
deeper way with a family member or maybe
you just have some free time and just
want to learn
babel is going to teach you bite-sized
language lessons that you can actually
use in the
real world yeah i tried it it's great
i'm i'm loving it actually yeah
15-minute lessons it's a perfect way to
like if i'm on the commute or something
like that
right i'll just take a lesson you know
it's it's not a big deal which language
are you doing
i'm i'm brushing up on my spanish
because i used to be conversational but
it's been so long
and i've been wanting to get back into
it but i'm not going to sit in my on my
laptop and take courses or anything so i
know right it's the convenience of it
that i really liked
other language apps use ai for the
lesson plans but babel lessons were
created by
actual people like language experts and
their teaching methods
are scientifically proven to be
effective and you you do see the
difference right away the way they put
it
into practice you could choose from 14
languages some of them are
spanish french italian german um plus
babel's got speech recognition
technology it helps you improve your
pronunciation and action
that's key man that's amazing because
when you read stuff in a language you're
unfamiliar with or you're just learning
or you're even partially familiar with
you're sitting there going i think i
said that right did i say that right
i love this babel does this language
learning thing
better than anybody else out there so
right now when you purchase a three
month babel subscription
you're going to get an additional three
months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code
tastebuds b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code taste buds b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
promo code taste buds get yourself
an extra three months free
babble team devil dog sal team snowballs
me
here we go baby on what planet do you
think this devil dog can shape up to
what's going on in this snowball this
snowball took what the devil dog was
doing
and took it into a whole new atmosphere
you've got the cake of the you've got
the devil's food cake from the devil dog
you've got the chocolate uh icing even
uh at the bottom of the of the snowball
uh you've got the cream
there's a chocolatey thing at the bottom
of the snowball there's something
chocolatey at the bottom of it it is
cream
chocolate cake okay sorry just the cake
sorry okay okay i'm wrong
and i believe coconut okay yeah pink
coconut i mean
let's let's just start with pink coconut
oh let's just start with pink coconut
sorry because you see a pig
i just just i'm gonna make sure remove
all the extra ingredients you put in the
graham cracker and the chocolate like i
didn't say graham crackers chocolate
cream layer
i said you've got the cake of the devil
dog when was the last time you bit into
a snowball because
you don't even know what cream of the
devil dog then you've got marshmallow
and pink coconut i would say that's
where it takes a severe nose dive
because it doesn't need marshmallow and
it does not need coconut and the devil
is proof of that first of all i'll start
off by saying you lose immediately
because marshmallow is involved
marshmallow is
like marshmallow no i really don't i've
what you i've watched you eat s'mores
i like s'mores that's one of the only
ways i'll really like a marshmallow
maybe am i lucky not like mars those
aren't even real marshmallows how do you
not like marshmallows the marshmallow is
the most
overrated treat hands down by itself
by itself sure i i'm with you on that
but when you add it to something
it can really kick it up the consistency
of the snowball marshmallow
is thick sticky and chewy you cannot
hold one in your hands
without a travesty happening on your
palms and fingertips
it's not even you can get sticky you
think the devil dog doesn't do that you
can avoid
you can avoid that in a devlog if you
want and by the way only because of the
packaging
only because of the packaging you kind
of if you want a banana like i do with a
snickers bar as i've said i i honestly
i bite into a snowball and it's just too
much ingredient
it's too much i'm all over the map in my
mouth i'm like all right i get in the
cake and the cream which is fine
but then the marshmallow overpowers
everything the consistency
is that of a of a of it's got a better
name
it's got a better look i don't think a
snowball is better than a devil dog
it's got a dark soul in it that's
contentious it sounds evil the devil's
in the
the devil's in the details devil is it
doesn't sound i don't want the devil in
my mouth
i actually i actually would contend that
it humanizes the devil
because that's good that's right it's an
evil treat i don't
but also like the snowball already
exists the devil dog those two words put
together
devil very very interesting unique
polarizing word
dog man's best friend dog dog
the name dog the animal is in the name
of this cake nobody even thinks twice
about it
that means something's working a devil
dog i mean i don't know i i just feel
like a snowball
you still have not addressed my point
you still have not addressed my problem
with coconut breeze a whole nother area
where it's like wait what is going on
here
commit with the flavor profile and go
with it these flavors are not coming
together if i was going
to no no no no you can't shop and it was
the last round on shop and they were
like to today
you have marshall you can't believe that
coconut you can't say that you know what
she would say to me
the one on top she go these flavors are
not coming together they do
come together pimp when was snowballs
invented when were snowballs invented
they oh invented in 1947 74 years ago
they obviously come together because
they're still around
and i challenge you to walk into a
7-eleven
walk down the cake treats aisle okay
because they do have one also they leave
okay w walk
walk down that cup that cake snack aisle
yeah okay
and you tell me if anything catches your
eye the way the snowball does
why because it's dyed pink it's lavender
first of all
i was wrong when i said pink that's
called the lavender there's all
different kinds they
listen to those words on the coconut
pieces doesn't change anything for me
dude okay you bite down
it's one of the only forms of coconut
i've ever enjoyed first of all
you get just enough marshmallow to go oh
yeah i remember why marshmallows exist
then your teeth and tongue hit cake and
you're like
holy [ __ ] here we go and then you hit
this delicious cream in the middle which
until today
i thought was more marshmallow so the
flavors are coming together baby
they're not coming together baby it's
too much sugar in one bite
it's i don't need four different types
too much sugar in one bite it is
he says it is
that's why it's called a devil dog by
the way because it's a hot dog of
chocolate cake
and not and i don't believe so yeah i
don't believe that that's a hundred
percent of the videotape why it's called
a police officer you're saying the
chocolate things are buns
yes cream is the yes so the devil is the
cream and the dog
and don't you dare challenge me because
you didn't even
get the billy the kid reference in the
twinkie the kid i don't think you're
gonna get anything
recruiting poster appeared shortly after
the world war one battle
of bellewood
bellewood which purportedly gave birth
to the term devil dogs
no not the marine veronica jesus you're
not named devil dogs after the murder
this is not the right article national
devil dog day celebrates
what hey there we got our nickname devil
dogs from official german reports
which called the marines out no
something else i guess devil dogs were
the name of them
right there how do drinks double girls
get their name hailing from their
birthplace
in brooklyn where brooklyn at where
brooklyn
at all right spread love it's the
brooklyn way both are the devil those
are from brooklyn you know how much
crud that just gave them the devil dogs
were born in brooklyn
two fun-shaped devils food cakes oh
cause it's devil's food cake
yeah that's why you idiot angela
rebels food cake it's just food cake
hot dog dummy it's both you just told me
it was named after an old beef frank
you're a dog it's beautiful
it's a devil's food it's a devil's food
cake hot dog
oh stop it please it's devil's an
angel's food cake that's why it's called
the devil dog and then they took the
name from the marine
no the dog part is because it represents
a hot dog
marshmallow which by the way people say
mellow but it's really marshmallow
i know we marshmallow is made from the
mallow plant
that grows wild in the marshes the term
marshmallow was derived both from the
native home of the plant
and the plant name the egyptians yeah
that's right
that's right where egyptians is
mixed with nuts and honey did you
realize that marshmallow was from a
mallow
plant never knew never knew i thought it
was thought it was made of
thought until the second thought it was
purely chemical right
so so right so the devil dog is based on
hot dogs
no
you want to talk about crawling in a
brain that you don't understand
pimp is another one the way he phrased
that
i couldn't have phrased it more wrong if
i
tried to go back he writes in why
is a devil dog called that and then he
goes
devil dog as hot dog
pimp what the [ __ ] you do
it there's no anything goes it's the
wild west with his grammar
it's what i was never sending in
prepositions anything
like it the man will earn more in his
lifetime
than the last four generations of men in
my family
it is a disgrace no joke
it's not even if he would have kept
doing it he would have arrived that
devil dole
cake called that for a reason you could
tell us about it that's what you would
have googled
the devil dog cake called that for a
reason you can tell us
it's outrageous dude devil's food is a
term used by
towards hot dogs thank you bye
the part of the term dogs is an analogy
towards hot dogs
hence the name devil dogs you [ __ ]
all right thank you thank you just say
you were right
just say you were right let me tell you
something right now i i i didn't know
that
so i learned something and you're right
thank you thank you
i'm fine with it turn over a new leaf
here appreciate it so the snowball
sucks why uh everyone thinks that no no
no
not everyone thinks it's been around for
72 years i'm gonna call
i'm gonna call this at least a 30
deficit of a win when the time comes
okay a devil dog feels like americana to
me it's like right be
a notch below twinkie you ever throw a
devil dog in the freezer
oh have you no because as we go through
every week i don't alter the foods i eat
i eat them the way they
are meant to be eaten okay but you want
to go freeze the devil dog and now tell
me it's
great because now it's a different thing
then freeze it put mic smock on my phone
huh what's that
my mics off no no i'm not talking to
myself oh
tell me god tell me i said it already
would you say please i didn't hear i'm
sorry yeah throw it throw it in the
freezer go ahead
now tell them explain what you were
saying i said it already
what are you doing what's he saying i'm
not saying anything i'm listening to you
shh
what do you mean throw it in the freezer
tell me about it
it's one of the best treats but that in
yodels i immediately throw them in the
freezer
and they don't like harden but they
get stiff and cold and the cream hardens
and it is just gives you
another way to eat a devil dog which it
just gives you a little bit of a better
texture
hey hey did you ever throw a snowball on
the broiler
oh it melts down into a soup it just
gives you another way to eat it you
could do that with one of those but you
can't
because the goddamn marshmallows will
find i'll tell you what oh i love this
mack weldon
mac weldon premium men's essentials
brand that believes in a smart design
and a high quality fabric
these guys are offering a one-stop shop
for men's basics socks
shirts hoodies underwear polos
active shorts whatever you need that's
everything they've got you covered and i
like it because
i often am trying to find a one-stop
store
in in a brick and mortar sense it's very
hard
it's very hard to go to one spot because
sometimes you need socks and underwear
and pants and everything sometimes you
want to do a wardrobe overhaul
yeah and they have every single
essential that yeah that's why it's
awesome they're very versatile
yeah and actually going to look great in
mac weldon their underwear socks and
shirts perform well too
fabric technology is one thing they
boast it offers a wide range of
customized fabrics
that keep up with you no matter what
your day looks like like you mentioned
and that's impressive that's the dry
knit the warm knit the 18 hour
and that's important because you don't
want to start off the day with a dry
shirt and then end up with you know your
soak through
you don't want to end up the start of
the day with a well-fitting shirt and
then by the end of the day it looks like
a rag that's been pulled on by
by several people uh you know mack
weldon has created a totally free
loyalty program level one gets you free
shipping for life
once you reach level two by spending two
hundred dollars mac weldon is going to
give you 20
off every order for the next year i know
this do you know why
why i have reached level two how do you
like me now
you like me now i like you now i like
you now i like you now honestly i went
on the
on the website and i just like kind of
read what each of the
shirts were tailored for and like three
of them fit my lifestyle some of them
didn't but three of them did
i just went check down everything and i
did the overhaul when they became a
sponsor i did the overhaul my whole top
drawer right now is is loaded with mac
welding
go get uh some of these cool products
they got the a sweatpants they got the
vesper polos
they got the pima silver dry knit
t-shirts
very nice get that 20 off the first
order by visiting
mac weldon.com taste buds that's the
promo we're offering you
20 off your first order at mac
weldon.com taste buds and enter promo
code
taste buds m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n.com
taste buds and then enter the promo code
tastebuds to get 20
off your first off or
you almost stuck to dismount sally
how you feeling over the last 12 months
i feel like it's been 12 years
i hear you yeah you know what uh let me
talk to you about one of our sponsors
sure please
blue chew mm-hmm what blue chew is it's
a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra
see alice you've heard of these but they
delivered to you in a chewable form and
a fraction of the cost i've tried these
things
yeah they work baby i think i've told
you the story before
of a long weekend i had in vegas oh yeah
and then a lovely lady friend of mine
said why don't you stay an extra day and
spend some time with me
and you attribute a lot of that to the
power of bishop hello
blue chew
boy did we have a time
[Laughter]
uh well here's the thing that people
really respond to it's an
online prescription service so there's
no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy
it just trips right to your door and
it's discreet that's the big one if
you're not
aware of what we're talking about yet
the this is a product that is going to
give you
better stronger harder erections and
it's a simple process
to sign up just go to bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you're going to get your
prescription within days
and it's all done online it's so easy
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient
and strength for your prescription if
you don't like swallowing pills there's
no problem here
this is all chewable it's made in the
usa
they prepare it and ship it direct so it
is actually
cheaper than going to a pharmacy there
is really no
reason not to do it it just
you checks every box it's better in
every way right so here we go
uh special deal for our listeners try
blue chew free
free i mean that's another big one when
you use promo code tastebuds to check
out just pay the five bucks for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo cod
promo code tastebuds to receive your
first month free
and uh thanks bluechu for uh sponsoring
for messing with us
the podcast
i'll tell you go in the freezer i'll
tell you what a dog devil
heat hell no you know you could do it
you know what you could do with a
snowball and i promise you the next time
we go on one of our little trips
in the summer months like we do
sometimes i'm gonna do this
you could put a snowball on a stick and
toast it over a fire
it's gonna toast the coconut it's gonna
warm up that chocolate
it's gonna warm up that marshmallow you
try that it'll stay together it won't
because the center is
is really hollow cream doesn't have the
consistency to hold the snowball on the
skewer
right away you're out of your mind you
think if you put a skewer through a
snowball and you hold it over a fire
that stuff is not going to drop down
immediately no cream's not going to hold
that snowball on that skewer
the marshmallow crazy you're nuts there
you know it would be good you know it
would be good no idea
you know it would be good coconut oil
i don't i love it in an almond and an
almond joy i'm enjoying something like
on top of a cake or just like coconut
water can go take a
couple of water right well [ __ ] so is
chocolate soda i mean what are you
talking about
but the taste of coconut is still in the
snowball and i'd rather not have coconut
i
like coconut in the snowball am i a big
coconut guy
no but do i like coconut in the snowball
yes it doesn't matter because the reason
you're gonna go down hard is the
marshmallow
why because marshmallows
i'm never going to un say it like that
now it's it's marshmallow
marshmallow just it's it doesn't matter
it's one of those things
i know but it's one of those that's what
that's about i'll tell you about that
i'll take a marshmallow in a malama yeah
malamar's are great you know you can
only get them
that's what you thought this was no it's
not it's the graham cracker no it's oh
that i got mixed up for a second but no
you know malo mars are only available
for eight months out of the year i do
know that isn't that weird travel in the
summer
because they go down and maybe the
things you don't want to take a snowball
but that is
mostly improvised oreo travel but a
marshmallow
malamar can't travel is that why i
always thought it was because because
it's my dad's
they only come out during like certain
months september through march gotta be
in the odd in the old days the chocolate
would melt due to lack of refrigeration
but due to tradition and regardless of
modern coolants we still can't get them
isn't that wild
that they have the technology
refrigerated trucks to sell them
year-round
but they'd rather take the skew off the
shelves and not make the sales in those
months to continue the tradition and the
aura that the mountain good that looks
and tell me a snowball does it doesn't
delicious don't look at you dare look at
it don't you dare look how good this
what a s'more is supposed to be because
s'mores suck
because it never works and you get a
flaming burnt
marshmallow that half melts chocolate
and then falls out of the bottom of the
graham cracker when you eat it
malomar is like hey s'mores step off
this is what we're doing i just realized
those are the three ingredients of a
small
first time realize the twinkie the kid
is billy the kid yeah i mean
you're all over the place when you bite
into a malamar it does not
play like a small that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying they did it right
they did it right but back to the
how could you tell me a malamar's
deliciousness and you hate a snowball
it doesn't make any sense bro the devil
let's go back to the devil dog freeze or
not
good the cake the outer cake of a devil
dog that outer layer that chocolate cake
is a is it consistency all on its own
it's perfect i don't find that
consistency
any other snack that's not true
you get it you don't yes you do ring
dings have a regular devil's food cake
inside this is
a different type of cake bro you break
it out you can see the consistency that
cake
on the devil dog that cake on the devil
dog first of all
um has a musty flavor to it first of all
it's not even a
second of all what do you mean it's not
a musty flavor it's got it it's got a
it's got a very um uh if it's not
moisturizing it's gonna be a little dry
earthy flavor to it let's put it that
way it's got an earthy flavor wait what
what
what flavor provides you up in your head
when you say the word
in the way that earthy has a definition
in that way
chocolate cake has an earthy flavor no i
don't think chocolate cake does i think
devil dogs do it's got a very unique
flavor that i don't necessarily care for
but but the style of that cake the
consistency of it that you are so
much applauding right now i you find
that in a lot of
chocolate treats
where do you find it where else do you
find it because if i'm going to continue
the outermost every chocolate almost
every mass-produced like hostess style
chocolate
chips i've ever had that type of cake
here comes the argument that doesn't
make
any sense that is the proprietary cake
that the devil dog has
that is not the cake if you break it
if you break it in half and look at it
in a pro side profile and you break a
ring ding and do it the ring thing is
more of a
if you made like a betty crocker duncan
heinz kind of cake same cake in the ring
no it's not no it's absolutely not no
the texture is not even close
no one would agree with you let me tell
you something that cake in the devil dog
is awesome
let me tell you something the cream in a
devil dog is also
its own unique proprietary cream it is
not the cream in
any of the other snacks not true not the
cream
in ring ding yo it has a different
texture it has a silky texture
it's a silky creamy texture that is not
the same cream so the potato
is coming together with two simple
ingredients that have been duplicated in
other products
but they're taking their twist on the
cream and let me tell you on the cake
and they're coming out with a different
cake let me tell you why
let me tell you why the ring ding and
the devil dog have the same cake and
cream i will tell you why right now you
ready
as a man who is a proprietor of his own
sandwich
pop-up you don't just go
make a different cake for every snack
you go
guys we gotta have a little cross over
here or we're gonna be wasting a lot of
ingredients
you gotta have a couple sandwiches with
salami
you gotta have a couple sandwiches with
american cheese if you have one
thing that only has that one thing all
the time
you're losing a lot of product because
you can't keep it stocked
there is no way a mass produced snack
cake company
is not double dipping with their cakes
pimp is shaking his head agreeing with
me that doesn't mean
anything to me at this moment okay can i
tell you right now
april 27th is national devil dog day oh
it's coming up
yeah it's coming up right there what's
the date days away
nationally today sorry what day is
national snowball day
don't even bother don't even mother i
hear how the listeners laughing right
now
listen to me let's not forget my dear
friend
you i i you made the argument about
popularity with the kitkat and the
kitkat smothered the snickers so
so my point is is just because there's
no snowball day doesn't mean it's not a
more powerful am i not am i saying to
you
that the devil dog ingredients that
make up the cake are not similar to the
other ingredients yes but whatever the
process is
they figured out something that nets out
to be a
different texture i'll tell you what
they figured out make this one round
and make this one long but i'm giving
you i'm giving you
true true argument here are true facts
and you're dismissing it this is of the
snow
if you want up to any child true child
with wonder still in in its heart in its
eyes in its mind
i'm saying male female gender neutral no
i don't mean the gender but it's funny
that you
it it but you go up to any child and you
say to them
you presented both of these to them
which hello my sweet child
which of these do you find interesting
the sweet shout out to the children
say hello i know the kid i'm not walking
up to a random kid
who's this kid you just call them it
it's just now
go back because they're pink do you want
to get a kid that doesn't know if he's
coming or going
to child i go kid i got marshmallow i
got coconut i got chocolate cake i got
cream
coconut you think kid wants coconut go
back to the little debbie's
pimp look devil creams oh wow
that looks exactly like devil dog well
that's because that's what little debbie
does everybody knows this
little debbie's running a side business
and she's siphoning off the top
she's got she has she cut she slept you
were insane
prices but her ingredients are a little
bit more insane
a little bit more cheaper ingredients
you are insane
really there's a lot of sugar and little
debbie's stuff like you bite into it
you're like
the first bite i love zebra cakes
don't sit here and tell me that the
devil dog is unreplicated anywhere
when there's 80 cakes in the snack
off of the devil dog i meant everything
else that's
that's not trying to hide that it's
trying to be a devil dog all i'm telling
you is that the consistency of the cream
and the cake in a devil dog
is not found anywhere else i really
think that it is slightly different and
that
means something like you look at a yodel
you look at a ring thing you look at a
king ding whatever
they're all the same it's just packaged
differently i think that the devil dog
feels different on the mount on the
tongue the way you'll find the way that
that cake gets you
nothing my friend split a double dog in
half you can see
it's like a it's like a very fine cake
the devil dog
it's it's like it's like it's [ __ ] so
it's not [ __ ]
no it's not and then you get to there's
different ways to eat this
i mean if you want to talk originality
if you want to talk
them in half and i like dunking one side
of the devil dog that has no cream on it
oh and let me tell you how the devil dog
specifically the devil dog
cake is a it's it's a sponge it's like a
squeegee
it soaks up the milk heavenly i i mean
densely soaks it up it densely you want
to talk
you get a bite of a devil dog half
that's soaked in ice cold milk and you
bite into that
i mean the party that you're having in
your mouth okay is invite home but if
you want to talk to me
if you want to talk to me about
originality nothing's touching the
snowball there's nothing on earth
like it nothing people try to shoehorn
marshmallow
into everything no that's not what i
said you know that i'm right there is
nothing on earth as unique as the
snowball
nothing cause coconut marshmallow they
threw a couple extra things in there
that aren't in other cakes
that's fine but joe it's gotta net out
to be a treat let's go to the point
let's go to the polls let's go to the
polls let's go to the polls i'll tell
you what i do with the other half
i don't care what you do with the other
half the silky cream
off the other end this is far too erotic
and sensual for me right now
i don't i don't want to hear any more
about your devil dog experience i i'm
not taking it
you slowly lick the cream off the other
half
i mean we're adults here joe okay we're
not little children that you're trying
to
to pass off snowballs to i don't need to
get it doesn't i'm talking about we know
what i'm talking about i'm talking about
the silky crew of a double dog
i think something i think we've got our
winner right out of the gate with
comments
what john wayne gacy style psychos he
needs to follow
yeah that's right and that's how
everyone's gonna this might be a ninety
nine point nine percent two point one
percent
this might be our first hundred percent
to zero that's what i feel is gonna net
out here
nobody nobody's reaching for snowballs
okay not even against the devil dog
i think if you're making a list and
you're you're at the register
and there's a big snack cake shelf i
think you're going to
10 things before you go to a snowball
snowball for me
is at the very very bottom of every
snack cake
across brands equally shaking his head
for both our arguments i don't like the
placation and i don't like
pick a side pip well because now but why
is why can't we both be making good
counterpoints
why does it have to be all or nothing i
had to do a double take because i
thought this was a what's worse poll
devildog wins by default because calling
snowballs a treat
is so insane only derosa could come up
with it
and they don't even know that you chose
snowball but then they also don't know
that i said
sweet treats that's the winner
does she wins she wins she wins that's
we're calling our winner early on this
this
this episode follow at brianna
underscore q b r e a n
n a underscore q you have a dunk uh
oh my god forget about taking a a double
dog out of the freezer then not breaking
it apart
and then dunking the hole in the whole
thing into milk
is really great you do need milk i will
say if i'm playing devil's ad you do
need milk a devil dog
completely alone could be dropped dude i
have to bring it up i'll bring it up
because i'm a nice fellow and i'm a
great guest
right cause it's [ __ ] cake that's what i
said [ __ ] cake joe i'd [ __ ] cakey
i would love to watch you eat a snowball
because the flakes drop all over it
sticks to your hands you pull it apart
it rips the cake apart it's so
disgusting i gotta say something
it's not even a dry marshmallow it's a
sticky marshmallow
yeah i have not seen one positive
snowball tweet
i'm telling you this is gonna be the
first zero percent
uh the one time i had a snowball got
into a car accident immediately after
so those are just chocolate covered
clouds of nothingness
gotta go with snowballs devil dogs are
like stale hojos absolute trash thank
you
coconut end of story and also as you've
touched on before
devil dogs are not as good as they were
when we were younger
i can't i can't take that as though i
love coconut but those snowball thingies
have the
weirdest texture ever they do sing it
sister
i don't know what the hell a devil dog
is but it can't be as good as a coconut
paperweight pretending to be all right
let's go to the vote let's go to the
vote can i just ask you what you think
the percentages are gonna be i think i'm
gonna get creamed
i do though i really do i think i'm
gonna get crazy just give me a give me a
ballpark
i think this could be the worst
landslide of all time do you think that
we're talking i think you're tapping i
think you're tipping at least into 80
percent 80s me too at least
good wait how was the whole house there
only 5 000 votes
we had 50 000 votes last time i don't
know
that's it's probably because we called
it a sweet treat instead of a snack yeah
i'm sure
all right what do we got oh whoa
wow okay that is very close i mean
according to the comments that
that should not have been the percentage
well that's what i was telling you about
the taco comments if you looked at just
the comments
you would think tacos won by a landscape
yeah and they they got creamed
and then uh so here we got devil dogs at
58.7 percent
snowballs at 41.3 that is way closer
than i thought it was going to be
give in the comments how did we not call
it a snack cake
but it's what it is we renamed it nobody
you know what it means nobody cares well
you would just hell bent an episode ago
that m m's were not a candy bar so what
if it's like me posting m
m's and putting best candy bar it's a
sweet treat is it not
say the line wrap it up
savilecanocomedy.com for tour dates
coming up soon i'm going on solo i'm
going out with the guys
that should be starting in about
september uh
joe derosa comedy on instagram and
twitter we'll see you in hell podcast
available
audio back catalog wherever you get your
podcast new episodes only on patreon
patreon.com w-s-y-i-h
podcast i'm putting a little street
together here i love you babe
still love you i love you too taste buds
they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds